money changes hands all night long it's
not the kind that you can deposit in a
bank
but all that money
it needs to end up somewhere
you know this thing goes right
it could be your turn to step away too
you want to be me
at least i had
all your money in the bag i was
respected i was feared
when i walked into a place people sat up
there they set up straight they noticed
you working with the fbi i'm not the
[ __ ] rat don't make me do this please
y'all shoot me in front of everybody
huh come on
you're not on my side if you see me
coming you better run because i'm gonna
lay you the [ __ ]
give me a [ __ ] army
i can't do any more time doggy
so if we get jammed up
we'll hold them caught on the street
we've been trying to heal the security
for the cash we're not getting
wants
a
response
if i'm there and i gotta put you away
i won't like it
but i'll tell you
if it's between you
and some poor bastard whose wife you're
gonna turn into a widow
brother
you are going down
you